M3 is India's largest and heaviest
launch vehicle ferrying Indian and
International customer satellites
lvm3 M4 launch vehicle is ready for the
chandrayankari mission
tonight
is ready for lvm3 M4 Chandra minus 19
minutes question director Roger
foreign
based on the Readiness of Vehicle
Systems range spacecraft and TTC
confirmed by respective machine
Executives and the
prevailing favorable weather conditions
Mission director here hereby authorizes
for the launch operation sequence of
launch of lvm3 M4 Chandra and 3 mission
at 14 hours 35 minutes 17 seconds Indian
Standard time today the 14th July 2023
from second launch pad of sdsc sharp
all stations
director has given authorization for
launch
director
ALS automatic launch
on your screens you have just watched
Mission directors
being clearance for the initiation of
automatic launch sequence this is based
on the confirmation of Readiness of all
participating team for ranged launch
Vehicles spacecraft and tracking
the automatic launch sequence is
scheduled to begin at T minus 14 minutes
30 seconds as a part of which the most
critical control system elements are
checked for the launch vehicle minus 17
minutes very close to the launch time
control will be passed on to the online
U.S gallery
enthusiastic viewers from all across the
country gathering at Satish Dhawan Space
Center launch view gallery for
witnessing this historic moment
puppet
the countdown for lvm3 M4 chandrayaan 3
mission has lasted for 25 and a half
hours it was commenced on 1 30 PM
yesterday boil of operation of hydrogen
tanks during countdown
the launch vehicle stages are serviced
with propellings gas bottles mean for
stage operations
propylene filling was concluded more
than 16 hours ago foreign
we are very close to the launch
and the day of launch wind biasing data
is fed during the countdown to the
onboard computers to enable most
suitable steering of the launch vehicle
through atmosphere
up next we will watch a cut and razor
video on this machine
[Music]
moon this familiar object in the night
sky has inspired the imagination of
astronomers and Ordinary People are
lying from time immemorial humans have
marveled at the beauty of the Moon
used it to count time and navigate the
high seas
in modern times Moon the only natural
satellite of the Earth has acquired
added importance due to the belief that
moon is the key to our understanding of
the evolution of the solar system in
general and Earth in particular
besides Moon's precious resources and
low gravity have further endured it to
humans
a major space-faring nation has
conducted a detailed exploration of the
Moon through its chandrayaan program
the country has sent two robotic
spacecraft to orbit the Moon and to take
a repeated look at its surface chandrian
1 demonstrated India's ability to reach
the surface of the Moon at a place and
time of its choice
and with it India became the fourth
country to reach the surface of the Moon
in November 2008. besides chandrian once
conclusive discovery of water on the
moon in 2009 was praised as a
path-breaking discovery
the follow-on mission chandrian II had
an Orbiter a Lander called Vikram and a
Rover named pragyan in the past four
years the Orbiter has repeatedly
observed the lunar surface and even
today is working satisfactorily now
3900 kilograms chandrian three
spacecraft is being sent to the Moon
with the objective of making yet another
focused attempt to slowly land on the
lunar surface and to explore it with the
help of a Rover following the spacecraft
launched by India's most capable rocket
lvm3
the chandrian 3 Lander carrying a Rover
within it will be carried into an orbit
around the Moon by the propulsion module
a little later the Lander will separate
from that module and will attempt to
make a soft Landing in the South polar
region of the Moon
this region is of intense interest as it
has many permanently shadowed craters
which could contain water eyes and
Precious Minerals chandrayaan 3 Lander
has four scientific instruments or
payloads of which
one will study the moon quakes
while the other one studies as to how
the surface of the Moon allows heat to
flow through it
the third one will study the plasma
environment near the moon's surface
[Music]
fourth instrument will enable scientists
to measure the distance between the
Earth and Moon very accurately
the two instruments on the Rover help us
study the composition of the moon's
surface using X-rays and Laser
respectively
while the Lander and Rover will be in
direct contact with each other
[Music]
the propulsion module circling the moon
will observe the light coming from Earth
the only planet which we know which is
definitely teeming with life
this observation will help in
understanding the nature of Western
planets circling Stars other than the
Sun
as chandrayaan 3 undergoes important
tests and gears up for launch
thousands of ISRO scientists including
those who will launch it control it and
receive the precious scientific
information from it using giant dish
antennas already themselves for the
challenging tasks ahead
in the past their dedication and skill
have enabled India to earn praise from
across the world
let us wish them well in this great
Endeavor called chandrayantri
foreign
objective
chandrayaan 1 launched by pslv C11 in
October 2008 included lunar orbiter and
impactor
during the mission life of around 10
months chandraya and one had mapped the
minerals on lunar surface a quiet 70 000
images to help create 3D atlas of moon
and what's more found water on Moon's
polar regions
chandrayaan 2 launched by lvm-3 M1 on
22nd of July 2019 consisted of donor
Orbiter Lander named Vikram and Rover
named pragyan
the Orbiter is still providing
insightful scientific information
through its payloads like spectrometers
synthetic aperture radar and cameras
foreign
to the Moon
the spacecraft consists of propulsion
module Lander and Rover
Lander is planned to touch down at South
Pole of moon
the major 10 phases of the mission are
the first phase called the Earth Centric
phase comprises of pre-launch launch
accent and Earthbound maneuver
while the second phase is the lunar
transfer phase as the name suggests the
chandrian spacecraft moves closer to the
Moon next for eight phases are in the
moon orbit the third being the lunar
orbit insertion followed by the moon
bound maneuverse phase which Mark the
fourth phase
and next is it is now that the
propulsion module separates from the
lunar module six minutes
when hundred by hundred circular orbit
of the moon is achieved
the chandrian 3 in its sixth phase
carries out D boost
100 kilometers to 100 by 30 kilometers
orbit
followed by the pre-landing phase as
seventh phase
and then the most awaited landing phase
takes place
[Music]
directors
most of you might recall the chandrayaan
two Mission and the intense moments when
all the enthusiastic Indians were
waiting for the touchdown of the Lander
on the surface of moon
the launch view gallery
with the overwhelming crowd of visitors
we are close to four minutes from the
schedule launch time
gaining from the heritage of chandrayaan
to the chandrayaan 3 is upgraded in
several aspects for the enhanced
robustness through extensive ground
tests and simulation
onboard computer in the flight mode
automatically on sequence services
thank you
foreign
pre-flight pressurization of the
hydrogen tank commenced
as 200k
projects
minus two
Turtles
s200 boosters
we are close to one and a half minutes
from the scheduled launch time
foreign
programs activated
minus 25 seconds
minus 20 seconds
minus 15
10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 0
plus 5 Seconds
liftoff normal now we have a majestic
liftoff of lvn3 M4 rocket carrying
India's prestigious children three
spacecraft potato tracking
lvm3 M4 rocket car
[Applause]
s
foreign
[Applause]
close to two tons of propylene being
burnt each second
L110
[Applause]
apart from the strap-ons normal
the core stage has also commenced its
operation this stage based on
combination 200 stages are separated
oh hypergolic Earth storage
uh 25 and n2o4
now the s200s have been separated
foreign
closed loop guidance
performance normal
the tragedy of launch vehicle is closely
following the prediction
of
kilometer
is
we are 220 second past the launch time
current altitude is
135 kilometers
in the 200 seconds of its operation the
L 110 stage carries the rocket up to
175.5 kilometers altitude and imparts a
relative velocity of 4.18 kilometers per
second that is 250 kilometers every
minute
L 110 stage performance normal
[Applause]
lvn3 M4 rocket card
is
Earth stoodable problems
ignition is authorized
foreign
[Applause]
that's a piece of really good news that
the third stage has started its
operation the c25 stage has been ignited
is
c25
118 kilo newtons thirst in vacuum is
what the stage develops with its
28.6 tons propylene combination
of liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen
presentation
[Applause]
c25 yeah
liquid hydrogen liquid oxygen
is
foreign
this stage will add to the relative
velocity immensely
Creole stage performance formal
payload images
[Applause]
prestigious lunar Landing spacecraft
chandrayaan 3 moving closer to its
intended injection spot in the orbit
the propulsion module provides
propulsion for Earthbound maneuvers
translunar injection and moon bound
orbits
it also has a payload to study the
spectral and polarimetric measurements
of Earth and lunar orbit
the abbreviated name of the payload is
shape
among the payloads of the Lander module
the following are included a landmate
prob called rambha to measure the near
surface plasma density that is the
density of ions and electrons and its
changes with time
the second payload is chandra's surface
thermophysical experiment or chaste to
measure thermal properties of lunar
surface near polar regions
to measure the systemicity around
Landing site and delineating the
structure of the lunar crust and mantle
payload ISL ilsa is there
the Rover after its descent will further
the scientific study objects through its
own payloads
for better understanding of chemical and
mineral logical composition of lunar
surface lips or laser induced breakdown
spectroscope is included and if the
payload is the alpha particle x-ray
spectrometer
foreign
radio astronomy of moon bound
hypersensitive ionosphere and atmosphere
thermal properties
instrument for lunar seismic activity
Landing site
x-ray spectroscope
foreign
as we have told you about the
chandrayaan trees upgrades
in the aspects of enhanced robustness
through extensive ground tests and
simulation
during the last phase of Landing the
module will have a vertical velocity of
less than one meter per second and a
horizontal velocity of less than 0.5
meters per second from a height of 3
meters
the Lander legs are designed to be
robust enough to thrive the impact the
cameras are tuned to take pictures ahead
of the landing and enable intelligent
decision making for choice of best
location to land avoiding craters and
boulders normal
the successive pictures will also enable
the craft to determine its original and
Vertical Velocity in real time
laser Doppler velocity sensor is an
upgrade in chandrayaan 3 over its
predecessor
it helps to determine instantaneous
velocity of craft
insights into the behavior of
chandrayaan-2 in the last few minutes of
its descent has revealed to the
scientists the necessity for upgrade in
the guidance algorithm inputs from
various sensors are used by the
autonomous navigation guidance algorithm
of chandrayantri
to plan the flight path to the most
suitable landing spot
the engines of chandrayaan 3 are capable
of more gradual throttling also
promotions
foreign
plus 15 minutes
we have come close to 900 seconds after
the launch
currently the cree c is 25 stage is
thrusting
currently relative velocity is 9.29
kilometers per second
foreign
[Applause]
General 3 has attained a major Milestone
successfully mission accomplished
handing over to Mission director
Mission director the lbm3 M4 chandrayaan
mission accomplished its precise
satellite injection conditions lvm3 M4
mission is successful
the launch has also added a feather in
the cap of lvm3 Rocket you can watch the
Jubilee and congratulate three gestures
office to scientists in the mission
control center
is
[Applause]
up next is
secretary
thank you
congratulations India
[Applause]
and three has started his journey
towards Moon
[Applause]
our Dr LV M3 has already put Chandra and
three craft into the precise orbit
around Earth
170 by 36 500 kilometer was this
intended target orbit and it is
precisely there now
and let us wish all the best for the
children three craft to make its further
orbit racing Maneuvers and travel
towards moon in the coming days
so let me wish all the very best to
Chandra and three for its further
Journey towards Moon
before that let me introduce the team
behind this Mission the mission director
Mr Mohan Kumar and also the
and also the Project Director of lvm3
and we have also the mission director
for the Chandra entry craft the project
directory so over to them
thank you sir
honor of honorable minister of State for
Science and Technology and Departments
of space and atomic energy
Dr jitendra Singh respected chairman
ISRO and secretary departments and of
space
former secretaries of the department
invited dignitaries respected
dignitaries and invites I am very happy
to report here that the lvm3 M4 vehicle
has injected the Chandra entry satellite
to the precise orbit and once again the
vehicle is proved to be the most
reliable heavy lifted vehicle of
Indian space research organization
congratulations to the teamwork of ISRO
family
ah I would like to approach three things
here the vehicle systems are in the
continuous process of quality
improvement especially in the uh in the
uh event of our human rating efforts
towards making the systems reliable
secondly the payload also capability of
the payload also is improved by Mission
uh strategies as well as vehicle
engineering approaches we are in the
process of increasing the launch
frequency of this vehicle considering
the national requirements as well as
satellite demands
here so many improvements we have
Incorporated in this vehicle for example
there's 200 nozzle they are processed
exactly as per the human rating
standards
enabling us to have 100 NDT and the
inherent pocket erosion characteristics
are removed the 110 stage because engine
mostly it is a hundred percent qualified
to be the human rated Engine with
indigenously developed LED throats and
the pocket the back wall gas entry also
is eliminated and it is a perfect system
uh and the seat see to this stage also
is
perfectly uh actually
so we will describe all those details
later
yes sir I take this opportunity to thank
all the mission Executives because
[Applause]
Mission Executives for all the supports
all along the launch campaign process as
well as the launch
once the launch manifest is released and
Mission executives are identified really
this is a Penance of so many across the
ISRO centers our launch vehicle centers
vssc lpsc iprc iasu sdsc Char URC and
Sac along with all our industrial
Partners major players to the uh
the small scale Industries who Supply us
with all the deliverables in time
quality products the suppliers of
chemicals propellant ingredients a
suppliers of avionic systems and our own
goco facility operators actually the
industrial Manpower is really a resource
virtual Manpower uh everybody's efforts
went into this and called the uh also
the prayers and best wishes of all our
seniors retired Executives every
everyone's prayers and our own family
members I take this opportunity to pray
God Almighty for all the blessings in
the form of this success which was the
Penance by the Israel family for last 73
days and my prayerful pronouns for the
successful continuous operations of the
Chandra and spacecraft
for its safe and soft landing on lunar
surface and further experiments thank
you Jai Hind
[Applause]
very happy to note that our Chandra
entry has been injected into a nintended
orbit with very close orbital parameters
congratulations and thanks to lvm3 team
and all our spacecraft Health parameters
are normal including the power
Generations in both propulsion module
and Lambda module our our journey to
moon has begin now for the most awaited
soft Landing will be closely monitoring
and controlling the spacecraft from his
track Bangalore many critical events are
lined up starting from Earthbound
Maneuvers insertion into the lunos orbit
and separation of Lander and set of
dibose manuals and finally the power
decision phase for soft Landing I take
this opportunity to thank chairman ISRO
directory ursi and all the center
directors for entrusting me this
opportunity who were behind who have
been the motivational and guidance force
behind this Mission my special thanks to
Chandra entry project Executives
associate Project Director kalpana the
project directors project managers
across the history centers
uh were provided an excellent support in
building the spacecraft
my special thanks to the
the export committees for their constant
guidance throughout the various stages
of the project I also thank the the
various work centers and industries who
have contributed directly and indirectly
to this Mission my special thanks to
ursc council members group directors
Deputy directors across the ISRO centers
and this looking forward for the soft
Landing with all your wishes and
blessings from the god thank you
[Applause]
we have our honorable Minister for space
for space Dr jitendra Singh ji amongst
us during this historic occasion of
success of launching of lvm press why we
would like to hear a few words from him
over to you sir
[Applause]
it is
indeed a moment of Glory for India
and a moment of Destiny for all of us
over here at Syria Kota who are a part
of the history in making
thank you team ISRO for making India
proud
[Applause]
and thank you honorable PM Narendra Modi
ji for having made this possible by
unlocking the gates of srihari quota and
enabling the India's space sector
you would recall honorable prime
minister had very recently said
Kai is not the limit
and living by his words
I think the chandrayaan today has gone
beyond the limits of Sky to discover the
unexplored horizons of the universe
beyond
ladies and gentlemen
this day today the 14th of July 2023
is also a day of vindication
Vindication of the dream that Vikram
sarabhai saw six decades ago
he might have been short of resources
but never short of confidence
and when we see those pictures of
a launcher vehicle being carried on the
carriage of a bicycle
without any remorse without any
slightest embarrassment that is because
Vikram and his team had faith in
themselves
faith in India's potential faith in
India is a human and today here we are
vindicating and we are retreating
India's indigenous capabilities living
up to the ideal of Atman
and before I conclude ladies and
gentlemen as Mother India
enters into the next 25 years of this
Amrit Khal
she pledges
to play a leading Global role
in the emerging World scenario or 21st
century thank you and congratulations
once again
thank you sir
we will also introduce the directors of
the centers who have done all those
great work of building the rocket
building the scientific instruments for
Chandra and three the Chandra and
spacecraft itself and made all those
critical systems and also the
uh agencies who are going to handle the
rest of the mission path the tracking
and the ground state ground stations and
all those teams will we are here so I
request the directors of the centers to
join first director of vikasara by Space
Center
yeah
good afternoon India last one year this
is that turned the mission including the
precise Landing of the reusable land
launch vehicle
so with this mission
this is the seventh dimension of lvm3
the successive successful Mission with
this the success rate of lvm3 is 100 and
this is the ideal vehicle for gagena
some of the changes that we are
incorporating in gaganyan we have
implemented here
and the Mark III has crossed their
liability of 0.9 and engine forward
so I take this opportunity
to salute the entire ISRO Community
especially the VSC community and our
launch vehicle centers industry partners
for making
the stages making the sub assemblies and
testing in fact this is the third launch
of lvm3 in one year
you know that they're realizing the
stages assembling testing and then
launching three lvm there is in one is a
Herculean task I salute the industry as
well as all these resenders for this and
[Applause]
and I wish all the very best we know
that when the beginning is good the
ending has to be good I wish the very
best to the children for its solitary
Journey Through the vastness of space
and for making a feather-like soft
Landing in the fourth week of August
good luck
thank you
Dr narayana director lpsc
yeah
good afternoon to all of you
it is a historical event for Indian
Space Program
and a proud moment for all the Indians
across the globe on this momentous
Association of the successful launch of
the chandran tree
three in one spacecraft in the required
orbit with the highest level of
precision by our heaviest launch vehicle
lvm3
after the two launches of Elementary
vehicle this year this vehicle is
realized in the record shortest time
today once again all the Vehicle Systems
have performed demonstrated the seventh
successive successful launch
as you all know the entire spacecraft
Community has put wholehearted effort
during last four years and we have
realized a marvelous great scientific
satellite for this Mission the entire
vehicle performance is as expected as
predicted in fact the Precision in which
the satellite is launched shows the
reliability of this vehicle and we to
have four liquid proportion modules two
in the launch vehicle the yellow London
State c25 stage it has performed
extremely well along with all other
Vehicle Systems we to have two more
proportional modules one for taking the
spacecraft to the Moon another one for
soft Landing I think it is already well
integrated the system health is very
good today's success is the culmination
of the dedicated smart and hard work of
all the Israel team members and the work
culture of ISRO and the review process
what we follow I am sure all further
Mission operations will be a grand
success and will have the successful
soft landing on this occasion let me
congratulate and compliment the members
of ISRO team our family members who are
really sacrificed their Partners from
industry and Academia and the various
review for us thank you Jai Hind
[Applause]
Center so I request a director of uric
to speak
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I
take this opportunity to first thank my
colleagues from the launch Vehicle
Center for providing a textbook like
launch for Chandra antri on its Journey
towards Moon thank you very much and
as directly lpsc and director of SSC
mentioned realizing this kind of launch
Vehicle third launch vehicle within a
year's time is indeed a Herculean task
and thank you very much for the effort
that has been put by all the members of
the launch vehicle community and the
industry supporting them coming to
Chandra entry
Mohan was telling that it is a Penance
in fact it is a Penance of the Chandra
and three team for the last four years
which has come
today as a outcome it is sitting like a
brain sitting inside the head of a human
being on that Mighty vehicle on top of
that that satellite is was sitting and
it was such a such a happy moment to see
that satellite getting separated and our
work continues from now for the next 42
days till the we reach the lunar orbit
and
Touchstone Softly on moon so we'll speak
the rest of the things after the soft
served landing on top of a moon till
then thank you very much for all the
members of the satellite community and
the industry for your support which has
been continuing over several years and I
am sure will continue in future also
thank you very much
space application center Ahmedabad plays
very important role in our scientific
instruments and building of the
satellites over to director sack Nilesh
Desai
thank you
good afternoon everybody
at the outset let me
complement team ISRO for these excellent
work and especially vehicle team as well
as the project team and as we begin this
historic Journey towards Moon
well begun is have done as it is said so
I am sure that we'll succeed in our
effort and Endeavor to land on moon safe
and insecure manner with a soft Landing
after 45 days so I wish all the best to
all the people who have contributed
directly or indirectly
and especially to the project team
spacecraft team as well as my team at
space application center who has
developed sensors and other Hazard
detection evidence system which will
help for secured and safe lending on
moon so once again I thank all who have
contributed in this Mission thank you
director of this Center Space Center is
a chairman of the launch authorization
board and also realizing the solid
Motors of this rocket so over to
director sdsc star rajarajan
I don't know
honorable minister of Science and
Technology Dr jitendra Singh respiratory
chairman our mentors and the dignitaries
person here and the entire family
a very successful launch and Hearty
congratulations to all the alien 3m4 and
gender intermission
so once again the fat boy has done its
job and put a very precisely the other
prestigious lunar Mission Chandra and
three in the transfer orbit
because throughout this launch we had
many launch campaigns of C55 and 56
along with that we are proud to have
this in spite of the weather conditions
here we have successfully launched Alien
3 in in the prescribed join on the
podium please come all of you
please come please come here
thank you